be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we continue our discussion on
Batman rebirth but we pick up now with I
am Gotham part three now when it comes
to multi-part story arcs there usually
three issues or more and there's a
reason for that odd numbers are more
often chosen than even numbers but you
know with DC they tend to stick with six
issue story arcs but regardless of the
circumstances everything's done in sets
of three the first two issues are done
to sort of set up the story the second
I'm sorry the third and fourth issues
are designed to effectively enhance or
to add existing information and the
fifth and sixth issues are designed to
conclude everything and with issue
number three Tom King begins the process
of revealing the backstory of Gotham and
Gotham girl what we do is we pick up at
some point in the relative past not too
far but at some point in the past again
we're not given a definitive date here
we just know that it was probably a
decade or so but during a time when a
family was basically leaving a theater
this was very indicative of Bruce
Wayne's experience and in fact when I
first picked up the story I thought that
it was a retelling of Bruce Wayne's
origin which seemed a little strange
because the boy was older than Bruce
Wayne was when his parents were killed
but much like that scenario this family
is heading down an alleyway why they
chose to head down a dark alleyway I
don't understand where they chose to
head down an alleyway in the midst of
walking down this alleyway the most you
know predictable scenario happens and
they're held at gunpoint now where the
father steps in and tries to protect
both his wife and his son the man is
basically subdued the father is almost
immediately subdued and the result is
that the gun again is turned to the
mother and eventually the son but Batman
steps in here and Batman basically saves
the life of this family now for Bruce
Wayne this is a big deal because this is
effectively a repeat of the scenario in
which he lost his parents and this kind
of situation resonates more with Bruce
Wayne than any other kind of situation
despite the things that the Joker does
that Clayface to face the Penguins so on
and so forth they're usually part of a
bigger scheme in the comic book realm
they're part of a bigger ongoing set of
events in in Gotham City but things like
this that depict a family being held at
gunpoint in the same fashion as Bruce
Wayne's family when it's parents died
this strikes a chord and Bruce Wayne
immediately
Asha's out but for Batman this is also a
chance for him to be the person that
wasn't there when his family died and
this is what he does you know as this
husband and wife and son as they're
basically consoling one another having
survived the encounter
Batman tells them that it's okay to be
scared they're going to be scared for
quite some time that everybody gets
scared for one reason or another but the
important thing is to learn from that
fear to learn to fight fear and to go
forward a stronger person now of course
what we know is that this young boy was
basically Gotham and the young girl
presumably his sister who we'll find out
here in a little bit is Gotham girl now
the connection between Gotham and Gotham
girl and the events that we just went
over is revealed to us when we switched
to Robinson Ville and Gotham City now
with regards to Gotham as a whole this
is one of the big myths no MERS Gotham
is largely considered to be a singular
place in and of itself Gotham City does
have suburbs but it's still considered
to be heart of Gotham in and of itself
and so what we find is that the parents
who had been held at gunpoint are
meeting with a man from the Federal
Bureau of Investigation and what they're
telling us is that after the incident
whereby they had been held at gunpoint
that the boy named Hank had basically
become obsessed with Batman to a degree
the word that Tom Kane chooses to use
here is enamored but the evidence seems
to contradict that the evidence says
otherwise with all the various news
clippings and all the posters and all
the pinups and so on and so forth it
seems as though Hank has developed an
obsession with Batman as a concept in
addition to this while his younger
sister was not present at the robbery
because she was at a friend's house in
the end the experience that Hank had
basically rolled over onto her that she
sort of became just as obsessed as he
did with the idea of overcoming her own
personal fears now Tom Kings being a
little thin here with regards to you
know the relationship between a brother
and a sister in terms of how one's
experiences impact the other we could
really just kind of take it face value
that in some form or fashion he had
basically reached out to her and he had
informed her her experience or I guess
of his experience and how it changed his
life but the fact remains that his
sister Clair became just as obsessed as
he did or it seems to become a necessity
Hank did with regards to Batman and so
this basically shaped his life and it
shaped her life that Hank began going
around and committing as many you know
good deeds as he possibly could
volunteering different things like that
that he began weight training he began
exercising pushing his body to the peak
of a physical experience that that both
Clara and himself began to experiment
with you no forensic evidence began to
read about you know science as much as
they possibly could and this is really
just designed to say that instead of
them you know having some sort of guide
to take them through their own
experiences instead they followed the
exact same road as Bruce Wayne that
Bruce Wayne taught himself a lot of the
things that he knew he also traveled
around the world to gain a lot of these
experiences but he taught himself a lot
of the things that he knew and the
result is that he is he proved himself
to be a formidable combatant and take on
the Batman mantle and full force much
like Bruce Wayne Hank and Claire have
done the exact same thing in fact like
Bruce Wayne traveling around the world
they did the same they won't ever cease
they did you know some work in some very
dangerous areas and this went towards
expanding their view of the world but
also how harsh humanity can be and how
important it is to stand up for what's
right to do the right thing in virtually
any circumstance now the connection
between pink and you know Claire with
regards to why they're being questioned
or why their parents are being
questioned by the FBI comes into focus
when Tom Kane shifts the argument and
what he does is he begins having the FBI
agent ask questions about money
transfers now this is not usually
something that's handled by the FBI this
is usually handled by the IRS so it's a
little fishy but if that remains here
that if there's criminal issues involved
well then the FBI would begin to involve
themselves in the events and so at the
very least the FBI is just kind of
poking around and asking the question
why there's two new superheroes in
Gotham and where they came from but what
the parents of hanging Clair say is that
at some point while they were overseas
they got a request to wire a large
amount of money no reason was given but
because they were their parents and they
were concerned for their well-being but
also because Hank and Claire had been
extremely charitable people and how they
live their lives there didn't really
seem to be any concern that anything
nefarious was happening and so they
transfer the money and
and I guess a few months later Hank and
Claire appeared in Gotham City as heroes
who effectively had the same power as
Superman now again miss FBI agents is
kind of poking around or at least a
person claiming to be an FBI agent it's
just kind of poking around trying to get
a lay of the land and trying to
understand everything that's going on
but the end result here is that we're
getting somewhat of a mysterious
backstory we're not getting all the
information and so before anything else
is revealed the FBI agent effectively
leaves and as he gets into his car we
realize that he's using the alias of
matches Malone which is also a name that
Bruce Wayne uses and so in effect
Batman's poking around at the history of
these two individuals trying to find out
where they came from now in truth I
wasn't really expecting this I actually
thought that it was probably some kind
of a henchman of a villain or something
along those lines but this makes sense
this makes perfect sense you know with
Batman basically doing his research kind
of hunting around behind the scenes it
would stand to reason that he would go
as far as to look up the heritage of
these two people and to find out where
they came from but it also gives us a
little bit of perception when it comes
to Bruce Wayne as we talked about the
last video Bruce is not a very trusting
person when it when it comes to anybody
to be quite frank of course the vehicle
that he was driving was not an actual
car instead it was basically a housing
for his for his bat motorcycle I'm not
sure exactly what it's called you know
the bat wheel I guess I can't remember
but it's basically you know this this is
just a multi-faceted depiction of the
deception the lengths that Bruce Wayne
will go to to get the information he
needs it doesn't necessarily make him a
bad person it's just that at times it's
necessary for him to be duplicitous in
order to gain honest answers and so what
we do is we switch to Clair and Hank who
are in the middle of holding up a bridge
that seems to have collapsed and while
Batman is racing and trying to get over
there in order to keep things you know
in order and we're to both monitor Hank
and Claire to make sure they're being
heroes effectively as well as do what he
can to ensure the safety of those
bystanders we also see that while he is
able to do this that the entire
situation is being monitored by Hugo
Strange now as we talked about in
previous video Hugo Strange is a
well-known you know villain of the
I'm an landscape but he usually uses his
experience for his knowledge for the
purpose of manipulating other people but
he's really one of these villains is
kind of the hidden hand you know it's
usually a circumstance just like this
where it turns out that he Co strange
was behind everything and so while the
bridge is saved
I guess the bystanders on the bridge er
saved me Oh while things seemed to come
to a close eventually Claire and Hank
are met by the arrival of psycho-pirate
a villain capable of manipulating the
emotions of virtually anybody he comes
into contact with and so the question
becomes what direction are things taking
now but when that being said opposed to
comment down below and let me know what
you guys think about this story in truth
the Batman stories interesting um I
wouldn't go as far as to say that it's
one of the best rebirth titles of the
moment but is very lease it gives us an
idea of what direction Tom Kings going
in the idea of where Batman is heading
in the DC rebirth landscape so with that
being said we're going to bring this to
an end and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]